oh my kind of story right here and gold
digger knew all mm-hmm
submitted by hello is it me you're
looking for
I should have thanked that I'm not going
to dump are you looking for a widower
sake the will of her late husband to
secure a fortune but failed Wow
what's the fortune amount that I need to
know because if it's like fifty thousand
dollars that's not a weak bullet it was
in the millions she tried and what kind
of relationship did they have that were
the husband
I didn't realize yet didn't even leave
her that much but she had to forge
something that would leave her with
everything if I were to die
mmm all right so it's better soon that
we caught it on camera for you to
archive this case yeah yeah his fortune
was worth about six hundred thousand
British pounds lovely yeah which totals
to about seven hundred and seventy-three
US dollars ma but for the rest of these
dollar amount I mean everything I was
doing British pounds with you here yeah
so Newton Davies is this man and we're
talking about that's a weird name
shut up Martin but Dad not dad you have
to blame a dad anyway you can't be
judgmental English my name was Henry no
no I like partner did you notice that's
what a girl is good for is like you want
to say some tight at a man but then you
always got to have your woman bring you
down one night that's what you do to me
so you're my woman okay [ __ ] yeah right
now yeah yeah you should saw earlier she
was [ __ ] all up so technically but I
didn't see it so Han shut the [ __ ] up
right off let's go eunuch you that [ __ ]
what's going on here she's a baby that's
why I counted on it I guess okay I can't
do it so Newton he died back in 2013 at
the age of 85 statement he was married
to Marcia for about nine years and when
they got when they got married
oh that's why she is a straight
gold diggers I see that sounds like it
nine-year golden I see it so when they
got married he was 76 and she was in her
she was still in her 20s yeah
yeah so when Newton died in his will he
left 25,000 pounds to Marcia and the
bulk of his estate was left to his only
daughter
Paulette that makes sense that's nice
what about she better router she was
born
that's very true yeah yeah so they're
saying that when the couple got married
it came as like a complete shock to the
entire family
I don't know how long they were dating
but based on how they're reporting it it
seemed like they weren't dating that
long and the marriage just came out of
nowhere but they were married for nine
years after the initial division of the
estate Marsha challenged that division
in 2015 claiming that she has found a
will that kind of negates the initial
will but this will is all like it's it's
ridiculous because she says that she
found his will inside of a Doritos bag
in the attic of the lot that they lived
in so weird why what the all the other
kind of bags yeah that literally sounds
like somebody put her on the spot and
she just said some random [ __ ] what do
you find a welcome I got dirty toe bag
successfully that also sounds like a 20
year old dancers yeah exactly because I
just validated everything yeah so this
new will would have left her with
550,000 pounds instead of just 25,000 so
they went to court because obviously
they weren't really believing this and
the will itself just looks really fake
because there was a lot of errors in it
a litter on it there was gonna corns it
was a pink type of they was in pimping I
guess like one of like the obvious
errors is that it's in a document there
it was being referred to as a hurt
instead of a him Oh girls mine what the
huh yeah so that was one of them
and then obviously the fact that it was
found in the Doritos bag when this man
don't even eat Doritos
that's fuzzy would at least be the Sun
Chips come on no that's what you were to
go to little classier a Pringle can I no
come on man a little more sturdier Jesus
yeah and so they also had
a handwriting expert to look at both
wills and make sure like you know other
signatures of it and it said that there
was spotting signs of hesitation and
correction and that there was a lack of
natural fluidity so Oh who's Henry his
signature yeah you should go to jail at
least for being a little liar for fraud
fraud so she didn't go to jail she lose
the 25 oh that's a good question
oh I don't even think about that
probably already lost it that's not sure
that's it more probably yeah those three
years later right you little crazy
speech II I'm not sure if being charged
for any sort of fraud the only mention
is that she may now face further legal
proceedings from the daughter for more
than 42,000 pounds and rent at the home
that she was living in during the legal
dispute oh well that was it a fall and
ass [ __ ] home dude
what does og do he was a retired bus
conductor the [ __ ] a bus conductor and
what the [ __ ] is he make that much money
as a bus conductor they actually
describe him as a retired bus conductor
turned lollipop man no no no a lollipop
triggered a sugar daddy maybe that makes
sense to me so not only did she lose
twenty five thousand she's in the hole
for another 40 mm oh we don't know if
she asked you awesome damn she [ __ ] up
you have a picture of her and hopefully
she's really hot and was able to get the
old man hard this is Marsha oh I thought
it was going to be a white girl that was
blonde for some reason do the
stereotypes man typical voltiguers wake
up gold hair gold digger and then this
is her daughter and the dead her dad and
she's only 29
find something I have 76 we always have
the most interesting faces not just
kidding so what do you see she looks
like a bulldog say like three fingers
between the nose were topless that's
what I did such a large jeez come on Oh
judicial she was like a dude wearing a
wig and [ __ ] dude little bit I should
like wait you're late
unlike my homies
hey the ninja male damn my whole world
is flipped right now because I just
pictured all white people I know black
so did this [ __ ] I was a white person
thing um that's not typically a black
people thing black girl gold diggers the
more like right thinning they're like
yeah you gonna take me here you gonna
buy me this that's a long game usually
oh it's like the basketball star
dude that's a nine year investment it's
really patient yeah maybe she really
loved him and then she was just like
completely taken aback when she looked
at what was less what does oh yeah she's
lazy though why wouldn't you look at
your [ __ ] document so that it looks
real and I correct the hearse two kids I
used to have a dream where I wanted to
meet a very famous youtuber and have her
and pregnant me and I could stay around
and take her money maybe copy or not why
a youtuber Oh
Michelle Michelle Phan she's like she's
like Asian Oprah I would like to share a
child with it just so we can live
happily together or if she leaves me I'm
clearly okay I'll just take the kid and
the money no no all the money I just
want her to take care of me to the point
like a live decently you can't leave
definitely not live decently no no
without working huh yeah that's the
whole point on and get accustomed to a
certain lifestyle exactly and then
happen she's gonna have to keep that me
because all her husband again
Stedman they're not married awesome
boyfriend he can't get [ __ ] Wow you can
though oh yeah after extra nine years
that's California what is this like
domestic partnership a long rough ten
years is considered just like a marriage
yeah Oh in California yeah I thought it
was seven years in California
oh that I don't know if I just know that
this rule applies in California cuz I
don't want it I don't want to be like
those gold diggers that just you know
when you have a kid you take my X amount
from their income no matter how much
they make because I want to take 10% of
your [ __ ] I would just like to have a
good amount for the kid to live and then
for me to sit on my ass all day thanks
you know like 10k a month I was always
wondering why it's so hard to just find
a duffel bag full of money
yeah because people that have a duffel
bag full of money usually want to take
care of it yeah but what about like
those armored cars that pulled away from
banks welcome there's no like burlap
sacks with a [ __ ] dollar sign I just
trust in the floor because then they
lose their job but I feel like people
who would put a bunch of money in duffel
bag or kind of careless in the first
place thank you what would you put it a
double back good so I feel like it
should be possible yeah well if they're
like Mayweather's and they just want to
like yeah well maybe we're the banks at
Bank of America you don't even try to go
that's not even a joke no go to bangla
mayor campaign isn't just wait around
anything blows up that's true
don't kill me because of people that if
you have any issues of like if you're if
you have I don't have any problem with
this but let's say Julia's ballin out of
mind we get married right I'm completely
okay with her being the bread bread
winner of the family does that hurt your
pride as a man in all mine as a woman
nope you with the money you make right
now you can take care of me I wouldn't
feel bad I think I'm too stupid i I have
to feel like I'm an equal and if
someone's taking care of me then I feel
like we're no longer equals and I have
to like bow down and you should own more
part Alton I do speak but if you're the
red winner I don't care
also you only care as human oh yeah it's
a competition for you is what you're
saying there's a competition no I'm just
going cuz you're winning it's okay all
I'm saying is we wish I like it to be
fair fair fair or you're doing this so
what a part said Disko he's like okay
Geo
you have we were having three kids and I
want you to take care of the kids at
home let me provide it on this and you
could do on it or you care what that
said mm-hm
because that's a different thing because
you being at home and being with kids is
a [ __ ] insane job to them four times
so that's you know I think that equates
it might put in my iPad yeah I think I
would still like maybe this is just
innately in me to still want to provide
and produce something monetarily better
you better [ __ ] I don't think I'm
something without earning some sort of
income ah
I will Julia I'll stay with the kids
while you go make that money and like
I'll be like a Campbell where we do why
why is it why did the cam what because
it might not just be on cam Kuna he
adopts you want kid you are your kids
around that I know it's going on there
our kids first of all Dre oh thank you
where do they come from the ball sack
thank you what they're gonna be sleep
Jesus in the neck bed you're gonna allow
that for your imaginary children
yeah good woman oh come on you know he's
helping teaching yeah yeah they're not
gonna see anything I will lock them in a
room and they can do what everything
well I guarantee you though if I was
like the housewife and then my wife just
came in late without telling I made
dinner well I'm [ __ ] starting some
[ __ ] well so what happened your hands
what do you mean they [ __ ] broken or
something because I've been cooking all
night gonna give you a [ __ ] call as a
house over your slugging issue this your
dinner [ __ ] get in the garbage can no
don't touch me tonight I'll cause a
[ __ ] beat by the mission was with my
best friend because when I got kicked
out of my house and Aibileen with him at
the apartment he was working at Costco
right and then he I told my yo if you
let me stay here I'll cook dinner don't
worry about I got it
this [ __ ] he was over here chilling the
parking lot with his other friends at
Costco I would be some rice some tilapia
as a vegetable actually got extra cold I
put that [ __ ] to the neighborhood cat he
came back home I was like what's up dude
so you couldn't like give me a call
another brother
yeah till this day he gives me [ __ ]
about it I'm like no like I just made
[ __ ] didn't you see when you here let
you stand no because I think I was a
very emotional state in my life and I
just got kicked out remember a time you
were my girlfriend
okay we're dude and I was like yo you
know I hurt my back too and I still make
dinner and I actually give me time up
here and you didn't give me that [ __ ] if
I'm over here on them on the floor with
my backward and I made you dinner bro
it's like he looked at me he'll like
[ __ ]
oh so pissed Larry I'm have another very
low point of I got kicked out my dad
wasn't talking to me she was all buried
someone's girlfriend it yeah you still
did come to dinner [ __ ] [ __ ] well JK
news fans I hope you guys liked that
video once again remember if you want to
be involved just submit some articles in
law suck your dick now but seriously
though there's more videos up there